FOR FRIDAY JANUARY SEVENTEENTH
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER. OF PC
VISOR AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING
THESE PROCEDURES BEING MADE IT
HAS ALSO BEEN TELEVISED. OF
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO HERE FLORA GRAYSON HERE
KAMLAGER YEAH MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS QUIRK SILVA CARE RAMOS
SHARE. RIVAS WORKS HERE I HAVE
ONE. A QUORUM- WE HAVE CONSENT
AGENDA ZERO. EMOTIONALLY THE
CONSENT IN GENERAL LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I'M FOR
THE URGENCY REQUEST FOR US TO A
SEVEN YEAR REMOVED FROM CONSENT
FOR ALSO. OKAY WITH THAT WILL
BE THE ORDER WE WILL MOVE- ITEM
FOR RICHIE CLOSER QUESTION SB
TWO OH SEVEN HER TITLE IS OUR
MOTION MANNER CONSENT AGENDA SO
SECOND MOVE MY NUMBERS GROW
SECONDED BY MISTER GRAYSON THAT
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
I AM I CARILLO I CARILLO FIVE
WILL. ACT HI GRAYSON I.
KAMLAGER COME ON MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK SILVA I
RELISH IT FROM US AND I RIVAS.
RIVAS I WORK SIGNED WORKS I.
YEAH THAT MOTIONS PASS AND IS
THERE A MOTION ON ITEM OF
BEFORE THE CROSS WRITER SINGLE
MOTION WILL BILL SECOND. MOVE
BY- STRONG MOST SECONDED BY
MISTER RIVAS THANK YOU. ON MY
CENTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NO
CARILLO HI CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOW GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS. NO. I
RAMOS I PROMISE I RIVAS RIVAS I
WORK SIDE WITH FIVE MOTION.
MOST AS PASSAGE AND. IS ONE OF
THE RULES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS MEANS